excusez-moi monsieur je suis tout seul
dans un parking souterrain de nuit j'ai
énormément d'argent sur moi et je ne
sais pas où est-ce que je pourrais être
en sécurité ce que vous pouvez me
conseiller ça vous dérange pas si je
vous filme non pas de souci pas de souci
parce que je suis en galère j'ai
énormément d'argent sur moi en liquide
dans ma page de droite et j'en plus j'ai
pu trop l'usage de ma main droite donc
je pourrais pas me défendre si jamais il
se passe quelque chose
merci beaucoup
je vais surtout te faire dire c'était tu
n'as jamais osé révéler aux gens oui
c'est quoi je suis une cru
y aller tu peux me le dire
je suis une crue je suis une cruche
comme ça tu fais tu encore une fois
percer de plus merci de plus
depuis tout à l'heure tu es là tu
arrêtes pas de me fixer si tu te
demandes qui sait Renaud tu vas être
fixé
on parle pas mal
tu dois réussir à boire le verre de jus
d'orange sans toucher la serviette ok
c'est parti
ok ok
attends je vais te montrer regarde
et voilà
[Musique]
happy birthday
alors c'est impression d'être en
vacances
au soleil à la neige